[Музика]
привіт усім
, це я знову, мене звати Селена, і
я дуже рада бути з вами сьогодні
привіт вам п'ять у нас урок
англійської мови немає, нам просто потрібно
- Votto 11 одиниць  або всі, будь ласка
, придумайте Piata mclarson, подивіться на дошку,
будь ласка, ви можете побачити кілька випадкових літер
у випадковому порядку, але я більш ніж впевнений,
що ви можете вгадати, що це за слово,
тому що це тема нашого уроку,
і це наша нова  одиниці, які ми
збираємося обговорити, тому подивіться уважно,
додайте літери та спробуйте поєднати їх,
щоб утворити слово, що це може бути
кожна покупка Деніела Нави OST маленький
дивак Напа новий випадковий спогад про
нудотного
братті історія Купера словацька про
Тімон Ашока шахрай Я дам вам
невелику підказку,
перша буква C, це перша
буква слова, яке ми намагаємося
вгадати, а також ви можете побачити всі ці
гарні, красиві та веселі картинки, і
вони ваші помічники, вони допоможуть вам
повернутись  цього разу те, що ми є
Частково я буду говорити про OG, що я бачу
Верну Atticus mamacita - Val здається
гагаркою aaj ka ki просування по службі з резюме
it apprecia buddy - movin Я впевнений, що
ви вже здогадалися, і всі знають,
яка тема, тема
святкування  це, мабуть, одна з
найкращих тем, коли всі люблять
святкувати,
дякую всім, як урочистості,
всім подобаються свята, фестивалі,
паради та інші веселі речі, які ми
дійсно робимо, щоб відсвяткувати щось, о, Боже,
свято Бірми святкування каже
,
дані Ковіни оздоровлюють Guitar Festival Parade
Witcher kata in chi-chi-  chi Vives le
wretch, що я пропоную тобі зараз зробити,
це добре подумати і бути дуже
уважним. Я буду робити це разом
з вами, але ви також повинні подумати,
які слова у вас зазвичай
асоціюються зі святкуванням або
покупкою dynein  Будда
Ловаас ще акаш буддійська епоха буддійський
лама падьєу маті вячеслав ах
Віманас ватикан II Махабхарата Про святкування
проспект Кава  ni приблизний підхід
кожна команда покаже mahajanas varma
praça da, тож давайте створимо невелику
карту розуму світового святкування, я
збираюся написати її для вас, тож, звичайно,
перше слово – це святкування, яке є
головним, так, чи
можете ви придумати кілька синонімів  ми можемо
сказати свято побачити осінній фестиваль
фестиваль парад або просто вечірка
про просто з Шірою і що ви
зазвичай робите, коли ми святкуємо щось
ми можемо розважитися права місіс яку я
вибрав реверсивну привада моя дитина, щоб
ми могли весело провести час  разом
хлопчик Мустафа, можливо, збирайся моя Марайя
Міша
добре, що ще ти можеш зробити і з чим
ще асоціюєш
свято я б сказав торт
чому б ні так, тому що зазвичай ми їмо
дуже смачні та солодкі та смачні торти,
коли ми святкуємо щось торт я
я б навіть сказав: свічки свічки до
комутаторів маврикійський я комутатор, ми
зазвичай задуваємо свічки, що викликає
божественне бажання дрімати Requite torta quickie
mover to emo, а не Де Ніро Геум та інші  тому
ми можемо написати день народження, тому що це одне
з найважливіших особистих
свят, так, тож це лише деякі
приклади святкових слів, які
ви могли б написати, і я впевнений, що ви
написали набагато більше своєї фірми в
законопроекті Шиви Пуццолани Бхарати, вона знала, що вона  мав
якийсь дуже ключовий є родич Юкі в
основному Будда Невада новий і давайте
відповімо на питання що таке
святкування шуш турецька горілка Ваня так
святкування це дія святкування
важливого дня або події важливого дня
дико весільна подія скаже казак.
Smith go Ваня другий живий Nashik це
фактично ми тоді в Mahatma ви гуляєте
з vacubot і що ще це може
бути особистим моментом гордості чи щастя
: дядько Джессі буде висвітлювати сьогодні ввечері вона
особисто знає бажання на південь
Небраски миттєвої Одіссеї святкування сімейних
зборів  може бути сімейне
зібрання сабаша поставити просто іграшку
Датчанка розповів момент : s Брахма Сара MC
me a О, вечірка була Франція так само, як
чобіт турецького трюїзму аа фестиваль
або велике зібрання найкрасивіший
фестиваль Чеснея Aborn
Велика світка Ваня Нокоміс  наречена Сідху
Ява свято професійне свято
пророцтво Сахаджа Будди девіз релігійне
свято
релігія не національне свято або
свято Пакистан маджін буу мірний
Місурата добре, тому я хочу запропонувати вам
вивчити лише пару фраз і
слів, які ви можете використовувати, коли ви  поговоріть
про святкування свята фестивалі
та вечірки та інші речі, які ви можете
відсвяткувати оператори з потрійним дном
через плямистість лавового екв  uvalent of
Icarus загальне середнє за купоном
– це дані вечеря сер Пачука великий
культурний фестиваль культура
фестиваль вище культура фестиваль
сімейна зустріч це може бути великим святом,
якщо у вас велика сім’я або маленька,
якщо ви просто запросите учасників  про ваше
сімейне новосілля, це
цікаве, я сказав, що влаштувати
новосілля, яке ви отримали
Nevada nova silica live.
або у неї
вечірка на відпочинок на День матері я думаю зрозуміло
так, це день іменини всіх мам,
він чимось схожий на твій
день народження, але це день твого імені,
як ми зазвичай називаємо в Україні
день ангелів, ніч нового року ніхто
Женева релігійна церемонія читання йому
церемоніальна школа випускні бали майстерність нева
поским весільний прийом васила парад пірат
і карнавал дійсність карнавал
добре зараз yo  Ви можете звернути увагу на
картинки до перекладу та на
слова, які ми мали на попередньому слайді,
і вам пора записати
слова, особливо ті, які є для вас новими,
і ви можете побачити
переклад, тому це дуже  вам легко
просто відкрити свої книги, щоб
записати слова з перекладом, і якщо
хочете, ви також можете намалювати маленькі
малюнки, ймовірно, вони допоможуть вам
краще зрозуміти слова, тому пообіцяйте
мені, що ви збираєтеся читати разом
зі мною першим  одна вечеря або
сімейна вечеря чи сімейні посиденьки дивіться
- гнилі емоції викликають на вечері,
коли ми запрошуємо своїх родичів на
сімейну вечерю, коли організатори
влаштовують сімейний обід, сімейна зустріч
процес, коли кожен окремий член
сім'я збирається релігійна церемонія
релігія на церемонії наживо на вечірці
Prashar Nieuwe Kerk напередодні Нового року
ніхто підліткова школа випускний вечір буска
весільний прийом васила названий день
неонова хула  - ooh - блювота Eamon
Abedini Angela Культовий фестиваль або немає
фестивалю вище фестивалю Cool Tori
Новосілля Vegeta's Nahor de
Nova Cielo і карнавальний карнавальний
парадний папуга, тому я сподіваюся, що деякі слова
були для вас новими, і це слова
та фрази, які можуть допомогти  ви говорити
про урочистості та говорити більше, щоб
мати можливість говорити зараз. У мене є невелике
завдання для вас, багато хто з нас знає, якщо
Даніель дістане їх за кордон, зараз у CPC чи
ієрархія Yaba це називається святкувати
хороші часи, тому це лише  коротка
анотація з тексту пісні
травма зв'язки з єдністю мир нове
благодійне шоу зумер Булова має
розповсюдити фотографію корони
урвища тафти тепер має право активувати
це відео, і я хочу, щоб ви знайшли
тернину в Інтернеті та послухали
його та  заповніть прогалини або просто
лопатою, але не було перевіреного супового
снігу, зимового рідного, ви так щасливі
розслабтеся або оголетеся правильні лижі ми даємо бачату зберегти Ловаас табір Міленка
служити  d Аня, так, якщо ви хочете, ви можете
призупинити відео прямо зараз і зробити це
прямо зараз, або якщо ви дивитеся нас по
телевізору, ви можете просто сфотографувати
екран,
і ви можете побачити красиві картинки
листівки запрошення автомобілів і я просто
хочу  ви говорите дуже голосно
назву свят разом зі мною,
дивіться молекула Стів Кей як
авансцена / МП Россума boo boo de la
savate і т.д. і т.д. на вершині reiki a це
могутня шиншила stivity, тому першу
ви можете побачити з будинком  там говориться, що
домашній милий дім був, що на
новосіллі Dr.  Vischer cosna
gordon of Isildur наступна наступна
листівка каже, що щасливі квитки до Дня матері
не о, це ж День матері,
правильно, а що з цієї картини, як
ви думаєте, що це може бути, ми можемо побачити
гарне яйце, яке розфарбоване й
прикрашене, воно повинно про вас  a
kuhar no crashing charisma liova заперечує
і це ініціатива пам'яті, ви можете побачити
девіз Моше Будди, звичайно, це
велика річ, Великдень, я чую, що все
зрозуміло, тому що там написано про пошкодження випускного вечора,
а людина F каже, що Роза, мелена, людина, яка
кричить на випускний вечір Фарвелл I
маю запитання до вас, що це означає,
що вона каже, Нечаєв, дуже добре, добре.
вітаю з днем народження, по
ім вітаю з днем іменин, на листівці також є назв
свята хід че
ез млин додавання аміак
Дана Регіна і що це говор
ть ха  щасливі учасники нового року
- раб Моше Олівер Селіванов
О Героку, а на останньому написано, що ми
одружимося, як ви називаєте це,
коли двоє людей збираються одружитися
яке свято яке святкування
у них буде у них весільна
набережна salud
you can  дивіться розпочато кожну сцену, тому
остання пов'язана з весіллям, якщо
питання знущатися зі мною пронизане
небезпечно. Стів іди - Крістіан не має
особистої звички до пози Кулебри,
лайм, ти прив'яжи мелодію без міста, мій кадр,
це, над яким я рухаюся amo  з
новим роком, з
днем народження, з днем іменин, з Днем ма
ері тощо, а та
ож є деякі фрази, які можуть бу
и дуже цікаві та дуже корисні, і це фраз
, які ми зазвичай
икористовуємо, коли говоримо про святкува
ня про особисті урочистості про будь-
кий інший підхід до
святкування  час або припустимо, що це рівняння
для mojo, щоб побачити Passat, це Anna
Tovar PT Frazee Aquila версія жінок,
тому першою з них буде задувати свічки za
duty c  eviche принести удачу вимовити
Adagio святкувати дні народження la parte de
niro Ginga слідував їхнім традиціям
ковзнув по Tredici оренда lima не
лімузин бічний феєрверк розміщений
soluti зробити тост
прополіс видалення стрічки розклеїти
прикраси
Фелісіті зволікати een розпочав з
кладовищем досягти їх рідко a  лук
розгорнути подарунки Шершень аа Борис, який
відзначив дядька батька я знаю, що ми
багато говорили про різні часи та про
минулий простий час, а саме, але я хочу,
щоб ви трохи переглянули
звичайні як правильні, так і неправильні дієслова
yes Aisha mabh SuperDuper easy  побачити
Якубу справді професіонала з нещодавно зарядженим псевдонімом,
ким вона повинна поділитися як
постурально, ймовірно, Шарра відшліфував о,
дійсно
Дхрува формаджі рукав
апокаліпсису, Джованні, мабуть, ключовим
моментом був рідний планшет, тож
вам потрібно зробити деякі форми
інфінітивів або  друга форма так, тож
ви
повинні додати пропущені слова алгебра, але зробіть
це labaik ніколи не st  ay, дитино,
але ваш час я повинен вирішити проблему
звичайне дієслово ми просто повинні використовувати ad
mundo de llamada продовжувати ідіот лекція
1 про проблему нерегулярна ми повинні
шукати в таблиці карти будь-якого
конкретного типу або свідок, що автомобіль Porsche
робить  у вас є підказка для відбілювача, так що подорожі
подорожували робота спрацювала
Yahoo Choo взуття Boozer Адам Ной
чавалла Арізона Талліхо були справжнім
магнітом Isla від Disney була дитиною, тому
робота працювала, ви можете побачити друге слово,
тож що таке перша форма, яку мозок
привів, взяли іди  пішла в недійсність
запрошена відсвяткувати відсвяткувати зробити
найнято найнято чи слідкуйте за чекати
чекали думаю дати дали виграти одна
гра гра принесли принесли були
швидкість попередній перегляд сьогодні вона
математики краснуха ще Java
бюджетна масова модель від природи,
ймовірно, знає мотохаші в сахаджа
вкрала але останнє  чашка досягнень
відбілювач гарне шоу Каїда відбілювач іду
затяжки видаляють хвилю Г. Г. Слов'янське ухилення як
ніч і я також хочу пограти в
маленьку гру і цю гру  називається
змії та драбини
Садашіва да Махара міс Тіна Престон
земля
яказа байти, як я II падіння жінки іду
бюджету goodra boy махати трійкою
і 1/8 геть
PJ Матіс Нахор О колонка, але відповів
oz chocolate in Co Tom the yes Mia we
opus  coyote some veneers так, це
дуже легко, а також ви можете побачити багато
слів, усі ці слова пов'язані з
темою нашого святкування, і все, що вам потрібно зробити,
це дати мені другу форму
дієслова, але бюджет see just
tsuzuku vine становить  показ Тревіса Роберта
Требека переоцінений для MU G повільно,
але проблема відеоматики так багато
в проблемі Yahoo дуже pshaw Ім'я Будди
ну намалював він для мене pochamma mm
другий Shinya ID, щоб маневрувати моєю
стабільністю Ішікава намалював, хто форму добре, так що
давайте мати  кілька дій ACMA motion був
проблемою з вони вбивають Cara є
відносною національною дорогою клацання, як зонди
Робін добре, у мене є тільки один так, так що номер
один святкуємо святкування
походження логотип Джуно продовжуйте вище la
mo eg c  elebrated epic Ouya Rio e KO
Cooper конденсатор C якщо C є лава попереднього
семестру, який був нічним роком, вона була
Надією чашкою Равана намалювала її для Мати,
цього разу в мене є чотири, тому мені доведеться
переміститися на чотири кроки один два три чотири, і
я створив  create знову є звичайним дієсловом,
тому нам просто потрібно додати історію створення IDI,
але це показує хід,
проблема полягає в тому, що ви бачили, як вони наближаються до mm
О, Еді, у мене буде ще одна мета, я маю
зробити, тому я зроблю два кроки один два у мене
є  тримай, це цікаве, тримай
драматично над зондом або виявленням
хубарама Просекко Ваня
Якоб Будда намалював її колишнє здоров'я, тому,
якщо ви не знаєте, подивіться в
таблицю, і, ймовірно, у мене буде остання
мета, на цей раз у мене три, так, один
два  три, це дуже гарне слово
безпрограшний Озма Чая парама гаряча йога
друга форма один добре, тому один раз,
якщо хочете, ви можете просто призупинити відео
та перевірити себе, перевірте, які
слова ви знаєте, а які ще не знаєте,
або можете  сфотографувати
екран, а також ви можете перевірити себе,
і у мене є невеликий тег, тому ми знову поговоримо
про минулу просту форму
дієслів буде читати про мій останній день народження
приніс мені Остін премію за тільки тоді
родій, і ви повинні виправити
помилки dr  .  Месі атакує я не буду мати
мана весело на молочний, якщо ми
вискочить супермолочно і я буду їсти блювоту
смажену курку вічність визнала Аппа
мая трохи химерна форма агресивне лайно
дивіться Слава, щоб ви прочитали текст разом
зі мною і ви повинні виправити  помилки
добре, тож давайте прочитаємо це разом минулого року
я влаштував чудову вечірку на мій день народження
Денис / Milkha Manolo Heroku oh man a
bullet Sedova vecerka у мене є
хвилини пеніса я довів, я став на рік
старшим, і мені довелося святкувати це так,
стоп  тепер перезапустіть деякі книги в павільйоні,
як завжди, невідповідний квадроцикл, як завжди я
організував фантастичне святкування у своєму домі
yahan нагадує кожен рік KO yke shadow
organizuj, де помилка, яку це слід
було організувати.
друзі мої,
ви сильно перемістили зрушення це
авансцена стріляли наток надіслали мені
бульбашке наприклад інгібування сопрано Еллісон
проблема в тому, що він лава він намалював її колишній
буддист і Евернхем тоді  Я ставлю наші
прикраси та готую смачну їжу,
чувак Сабріна, я ставлю каструлю для зволоження
c34 MODOK, ми
готуємо смачну їжу, абрикос, розвиваємось,
розбиваючи Алісія, готую мої думки
Minina приготувала бульбашку, яку вона Еді,
і фантастичний день разом Мачадо,
мабуть, Чарльз  витратила Міс Мінні Мона
витратила друга за гроші напевно роки
лава моя мама спекла для мене величезний шоколадний пиріг
моя мама пророк Аллаха псевдо VPD
тур оргія спекла міс Мінні Амана спекла
перед тим, як їсти торт, всі співали з днем
одження і я задуваю свічки CSP ball
s  ім'я neuro jigna Єва пряжі у Боба
севіче або ябломе є Нене Амана блакитна
машіта немає проблем ніндзя повільніше нарешті
Валеро феєрверк і розгортає подарунки,
якщо бачить мене поштовий салют справа
Варкі вуха болять Алі поставила власний ключ
нехай часто людина з NAS  мабуть, не
дозволяю пропустити переді мною та
розгорнути мій PO Vania дані другий
Shinya EG e Parvo majide
Попередній перегляд Шарри чи вона розповіла про це  eally
awesome synergy, ймовірно, наливає молоко,
але якщо це схвалення у вигляді
мандали, яка також мала організований пісок,
зварений, витрачений запечений синій розгорнутий,
і останнє для вас, це
здавалося мені дуже весело багато разів для моїх
факторів THC смачна економія кожного  cos
gamma agility параметр адитья як
міркування cregeen має солодкий Кевон
ще Jana Regina алібі бичачий німецький
маніока Pavini podomatic навіть білок
кожен у квітні щодня в Такаші Ом
тому що ви, ймовірно, знаєте Віто Віто jumbo
Будда Матата один за одним порядковий номер Одіна
і вирішуватимете
правдиві вони чи хибні, тому ваше завдання після того, як я
прочитаю речення, ви повинні голосно сказати мені
, правда це чи неправда, і я покажу
вам свої ознаки. У мене є два з них.
кажу вам правильну відповідь, добре, тож
давайте прочитаємо першу в ном
ви не старієте в день свого
народження і не святкуєте, ви стаєте на
рік старше в день Нового року
K  itakami Fox шоу В'єтнам, ти пропустив
рік, статичний старт Матаджі однаково
бути збоченцем природи ВМС ах, сестро, ти
починаєш зменшувати масштаб, а потім не читаєш нічого з
читання, тож як ти думаєш, це правда
чи неправда,
це може здатися дуже дивним, але це
правда  Farage etroesch будь сміливим зараз я
дозволю собі проблему добре наступний у
Великобританії діти зазвичай випускають феєрверки на
свої дні народження перемикач я думаю, що
вони втратили забруднення amok полегшив мені
листівку салют, якщо ви працюєте в Швеції
Раджа що ви думаєте про  ця
традиція
здається дуже приємною, насправді я б
хотів мати таку традицію, але
це помилкова черга квітневої примадонни, це може бути
небезпечно,
так, це також коштує багато грошей, тому
ця традиція не відповідає дійсності наступна традиція
в Угорщині, коли іменинник або іменинник  дівчина
розгорнула присутність його чи її
вуха тягнуть перед церквою Shinya Kali Klub
Єгипетський космічний слиз із
нейронами в еросі її щитовидна залоза для
звичайної тієї ж миті, коли ти Джанет забу ха
що ти робиш  nk у нас є традиція,
яка дуже схожа на цю,
але, на жаль, це неправда,
так, насправді хлопцям чи дівчатам
тягнуть за вуха, але не під час процесу
розгортання подарунків.
День народження торт
Alvah обов'язково клуб похитнув єгипетська
люб'язність може і Regina О відбілювачі та
інше, як він зберігає
аркуші є проблемою, і я скажу вам,
що це
правда, це може здатися дивним, так, але
це справжня традиція і остання в
деяких частинах Канади  іменинниця
чи хлопчики ніс змащують маслом так
Таня BHS Тіна Кеннард
зараз то живлення ти сподіваєшся досягти
ефективності нама повинен ніс мусульманин що
ти думаєш про цю традицію
це правда чи помилка традиція смерті
вірна це реклама сніг Правда яка майстерність
на церемонії до без сидіти Адажіо, так що
це правда, я сподіваюся, що я
трохи розважу вас своїми заявами, а тепер
я  Настав час переглянути те, що ми навчилися,
і перевірити себе. Відділ
імовірності вимірювання Шама практично
не має навичок коментарі чилі добра, тому
оберіть правильний варіант, щоб запалити
свічки, задути свічки
або задувати, можливо,
задути  свічки виберіть варіант, який
не має відношення до святкування або означає, що
Шанель не соромиться Nesta suet, просто
дозвольте Кевону особистий момент смаженого або
щастя звичайний рутинний шкільний день,
сімейні збори або фестиваль, вечірка
була друзями або просто показана в моїй
обробці  звичайний рутинний шкільний день,
звичайно, не є святом,
і останній вибирає неправильну форму минулого,
ми створюємо її на понеділок, мабуть, не маємо
уявлення, схил означає, що подорожували чекали загорнуті,
тому ви можете вирішити проблему, товариш, добре,
мадам, сер Муслим із просто королів  завтра
так, віруси puja доставляться в одному місці вище
скажи, що ми обидва залишимо рахунок Aslam,
нам пора закінчити, мені було дуже
приємно бути з вами сьогодні, я сподіваюся, що ви
дізнався дещо цікаве. Я бажаю
тобі мати сірий
день у день, до скорого побачення
[Музика].